guys welcome back to brand-new video
we're back on foreigner getting yes
today again we are in my car recording
this video god I [ __ ] hate college
but either way we got some interesting
news International tribute which I'll
get to it towards the end of the video
but real quick we're just gonna go over
the new content of the week cuz that is
the most that's the longest thing that's
the most important thing it's good
through at that so first up the snowball
emote is back on the shop so if you
didn't get it during the last frost one
festival you can now get the snowball
emote I've been using it since the
beginning so it's not a big deal to me
but it's for every single character
including Bret black prior the Wulin and
the new DLC characters that didn't come
out before then so now everyone can get
it on top of that there's actually new
signatures as well I have it I remember
I said when signatures were first leaked
the next couple weeks would beginning
signatures and then a couple weeks after
that we might be getting new ones I was
apparently two and a half months off but
no worries we still finally got some new
signatures they're pretty cool some of
them look nice some of them pretty
flashy but the most important one is for
the Berserker players now if you're a
berserker player you actually don't have
to pay steel for this one the Berserker
emote or the Berserker signature is free
for every single person in the game
because it is a tribute to Stefan Carl
Steffensen who is the guy of the we are
number one meme if you guys have seen
that that was a pretty dead mean by now
but the creator of that meme Stephane
Karl he ended up passing away a couple
months ago to to like some stage 4
cancer which he fought multiple times he
actually ended up voicing I believe the
Berserker from the campaign and or the
multiplayer so he was part of four
honors development so in that little bit
of a tribute the berserker emotes the
signature is where he basically sits up
does the number one with his hand and
then he gets frozen into a statue
because you know he deserves a statue in
his hometown country so shoutout to
Stefan for that thank you for doing
everything you do for for honor and
appreciate that new signature even if
you don't play beserker
you might as well just grab because it's
free anyway and then the next last tip
bits of info we have is the event
challenge for this weekend and it's for
the most takedowns and ranked the
winning faction will get four XP boosts
next up is the Wulin hero trials now
they've done the hero trials a couple
times with the older DLC characters but
so it's nothing different
except it's not for the wolven I made a
video on this a couple days ago I
believe it's started on the 5th of
February and is now ending on the
February 12th so you about a hat you
have I think an entire week to do this
and you get to play as all the Wulin
heroes for free if you don't have them
and it's basically as if you unlocked
them in the beginning and you get to
keep all your progress so for example if
you play a Shaolin and you get him to
rep three for the week and then the hero
trial is over and then you decide to
purchase him again he will be rep three
again and it'll save all of your
progress is if you've never lost it so
definitely go try that out if you're
part of the Wulin or if you're fan of
the Wulin if you just maybe if you just
want to try a new character maybe switch
up your type of your play style
definitely go try out the hero trial I
definitely recommend it and on top of
that multiple editions of the game are
free and half off for PlayStation the
game is free right now on PS Plus so if
you have a friend that needs it go
definitely go tell them about it and
then on top of that the marching fire
expansion is also half off and the
complete edition which comes with year
one marching fire end the year three
past is also 50% off so there's tons of
discounts if you don't have any of the
DLC or if you don't have the game in
general so if you let your friends know
if they don't have it so that everyone
can get the new expansion and get all
the new heroes hey guys it's gonna be
the end of the V tale if we guys did
enjoy
if the emotes and the signatures are
still going on while I'm talking that'll
just be the end but anyway guys like the
V feed do enjoy subscribe if you're new
I cover the informational side of
foreigner that being balanced changes
here updates patch notes and leaks if
you want to be kept up to date with
everything happening in the world before
and or definitely steps up to the
channel my two most recent videos would
be on screen after the emotes or if it's
already done you you get the gist at the
end of the vid few guys do want to check
that out with a guy so have a greater
day thank for watching the video
definitely grab the stuff on Carl emote
shout out to him and peace out guys you
know the rest do day
[Music]
you
[Music]